so we're given this equation right here
we want to solve by completing the
square
but notice how we have that leading
coefficient that's not one so what I
recommend you do is make sure this
leading coefficient is one we're gonna
divide everything by three keep the
equation balanced this will make it
easier to complete the square we've got
x squared minus 6x minus 13 equals zero
now what you want to do step number two
is you want to get the constant the
number here on the other side of the
equation so we're just going to add 13
to both sides and so now we have x
squared minus 6x equals 13 so to
complete the square what you do is you
the third step here is you take this
coefficient okay the number that's in
front of the X you want to divide it by
2 and square it so negative 6 divided by
2 squared that's negative 3 squared
which is equal to 9 so you can do that
work off to the side if you want so
we're going to do is we're going to add
9 to the left side of the equation we're
gonna add 9 to the right side to keep it
balanced right so now what we can do is
simplify the right side and we can
factor this left side it's going to be a
perfect square okay because that's what
the completing the square process is all
about and it's always going to be half
of this middle coefficient so it's going
to be negative 3 if this was plus 6x
that would be plus 3 so now what you can
see is we've completed the square but we
want to take it one step further we want
to solve it and get X by itself so we're
going to do is we're going to take the
square root of both sides okay to keep
the equation balanced and to get rid of
this square the squaring the square root
cancel we get X minus 3 equals plus or
minus the square root of 22 remember
when you take the square root of both
sides of an equation you're gonna get
two solutions plus or minus then what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna want me to
think about this is to write this in two
different equations X minus 3 equals
positive 22 X minus 3 equals negative
root 22 and then what I'm going to do is
just going to add 3 to both sides so I
get x equals 3 plus square root of 22
and I get x equals when I add 3 to this
side 3 minus square root of 22 the other
option is you can just write here you
can just when you add 3 make sure that
you put the 3 in front of the plus or
minus so 3 plus or minus square root of
22 and you've solved it
click the video I did right there to see
more examples about how to complete the
square and I'll see over in those videos